Поки в деяких країнах ЄС роблять ставку на атомну енергетику, у Німеччині продовжують закривати АЕС.
Наприклад, ось ця атомна електростанція неподалік німецького Грайфсвальда не працює
вже 30 років, проте тут все ще небезпечно. Це місце просякнуте радіацією.
Планується, що колись тут буде чисте поле, але до цього ще далеко.
Демонтаж триває повним ходом. Але тут ще багато чого треба очистити.
Перш ніж це стане бетонною коробкою, пройде чимало часу.
Під час будівництва перших АЕС ніхто не враховував, як їх демонтуватимуть.
Станція у Грайфсвальді пропрацювала 16 років.
АЕС із п'ятьма енергоблоками закрили після возз'єднання Німеччини.
Тоді стало зрозуміло, що переобладнання станції через відмінності у стандартах безпеки між НДР та ФРН
буде економічно невигідним. Та й активісти масово виступали за закриття АЕС.
В останні 30 років цю АЕС розбирають люди, які тут же працювали.
Багато чого їм довелося робити вперше.
Це велика й особлива споруда. У багатьох процесах ми стали першопрохідцями,
ніхто до нас подібного ще не робив.
Ми першими демонтували дослідницькі реактори, першими розбираємо таку велику АЕС із п'ятьма блоками.
Розбираючи АЕС, намагаються дотримуватись стандартів безпеки.
Найважливіше: демонтаж станції має відбуватися без шкоди для довкілля.
Повітря та вода з АЕС потрапляють у природу.
І важливо не перевищити допустимий рівень радіоактивності.
Звісно, радіоактивність не нульова.
Але треба зберегти її якомога нижчою, щоб мінімізувати вплив на природу, екосистему навколо.
Це досягається різними способами: повітря очищається, вода фільтрується,
і все це потрапляє в природу лише після численних перевірок.
Більшість великих елементів уже демонтовано.
У тому числі реактори. Тепер із стін знімають тонкі шари покриття.
Рівень радіації у багатьох місцях все ще високий.
І от ми бачимо, якщо відмічали блакитними значками, то це означає, що поверхня чиста.
А якщо відмічали червоними, то ця ділянка була позначена як потенційно заражена.
Елементи станції деталь за деталлю та шар за шаром залишають АЕС.
Вони вирушають у або у тимчасове сховище, або за межі станції для повторного використання.
Ці елементи сортуються за часом необхідного зберігання.
Вони можуть пролежати у тимчасовому сховищі ще до 70 років.
А ось так у Грайфсвальді виглядає тимчасове сховище.
Тут зберігаються не лише ядерні відходи з АЕС, а й усі ядерні відходи з усього регіону.
Місця тут багато, але відходи не зможуть зберігатись тут довго.
Контейнери постійно відкриваються, їхній вміст регулярно перевіряють на радіоактивне забруднення.
Місця тут достатньо. Наразі у нас заповнено близько 70%.
Але матеріал із контейнерів весь час дістають.
Його відносять до майстерні, там подрібнюють на шматки, очищають.
Іноді деякі частини можуть залишити АЕС, коли вони повністю очищені від радіоактивних речовин.
Тоді ми відправляємо їх у приміщення вимірювання радіаційного фону.
І тоді в контейнері залишається лише те, що не можна використовувати повторно.
Навіть після зберігання та очищення деякі матеріали все ще радіоактивні.
Як, наприклад, ці реактори. Їхній радіаційний фон настільки високий, що місце їм тільки в могильнику,
де вони залишаться назавжди.
Нині у Німеччині будують перший могильник, куди звезуть ядерні відходи з усієї країни.
Щоправда, місце в ньому коштуватиме дуже дорого.
Тому тут намагаються очистити якомога більше матеріалів та дати їм друге життя.
Деякі з них навіть йдуть на продаж і використовуються, наприклад, для будівництва доріг.
За планом демонтаж АЕС має бути завершено до 2040 року.
Наразі демонтовано вже 80% станції. Але попереду ще багато роботи.
Проєкт цей - дуже трудомісткий, проте демонтаж АЕС у Грайфсвальді вважається одним із найуспішніших у Німеччині.
Співробітники станції вже діляться досвідом із колегами з інших АЕС по всій країні.